Let's pay careful attention as I read from Psalm 11.
In the Lord I take refuge. How can you say to my soul,
flee like a bird to your mountain? For behold, the wicked bend the bow.
They have fitted their arrow to the string to shoot in the dark at the upright in heart.
If the foundations are destroyed, what can the righteous do?
The Lord is in his holy temple. The Lord's throne is in heaven. His eyes see, his eyelids test,
the children of man. The Lord tests the righteous, but his soul hates the wicked,
and the one who loves violence. Let him reign coals on the wicked, fire and sulfur,
on a scorching wind shall be the portion of their cup. For the Lord is righteous.
He loves the righteous deeds. The upright shall behold his face. This is the word of the Lord.
Thank you, Tom. We'll be spending some time in Psalm 11 here in Abilah. Let's pray before we
do that. Lord, we thank you for your word, and I pray that by your spirit you would open our eyes
to see more of your glory there. And I pray that you would show us the surpassing worth of knowing
Jesus. Lord, I pray that you would help us to respond in faith to him.
For it's in his name we pray. Amen. Amen. Well, when I was a boy and a tornado season came around,
there were two words that summarized what you were supposed to do in the event of a tornado,
and those two words were hunker down. I don't know if you grew up with those words or used
them yourself, but I remember here, you know, we've got a tornado warning that's coming up
this afternoon. We're not going to be going anywhere, running in the errands. We're just
going to hunker down. And if you'll allow me to say this this morning, in Psalm 11 we see that
hunkering down can be a holy thing. And so I've taken as a title the holiness of hunkering down.
So what do I mean by saying it's a holy thing? Well, I don't mean that we should avoid
trouble, kind of stick our head in the sand, as though things aren't as troubling as it might
seem. But rather in the midst of trouble, we are to take refuge in the Lord, right? So we're to find
refuge in him. We're to remain steadfast in him. Well, in Psalm 11, the context is David is
facing a storm, if you will. He is being opposed, facing intense opposition. And it's not just
him, it's the people of God more broadly. And so it's very similar to a number of the Psalms here
at the start, which you will recognize if you've been here with us through the summer.
But there's something happening here. There's particular advice that is being given to him
about what to do. We don't know if this is just an internal conversation within David, or
if this is actual advisors telling him what they think he ought to do. But we do know what the
advice is. They're saying, troubles come, it's time to get out of here and get out of here fast.
So notice what they say to him. He says, how can you say to my soul, flee like a bird to your
mountain? I've heard that one of the shore signs of settling into middle age is that you take
up bird watching. Jared, I wouldn't know anything about that, would you? So I've taken that up
in recent years. And so I know there's been times where I've been sat on the back deck and looking
out and a specific bird comes. And I really am excited about it. I want to tell somebody about it.
But I know that if I get up, it's not going to be there anymore. It's going to flutter away
really quick because your birds can be pretty skittish. And so the people around David are
like spooked birds. They're facing this scary situation and their immediate response
is to flee to get out of there. But they're not spooked over nothing. Verse two, for behold,
the wicked bend the bow. They have fitted their arrow to the string to shoot in the dark at the
upright in heart. So let's pause there. So what do we see about this threat that they are facing?
Well, one, it's urgent. You know, I'm not a bow hunter, but I know that you're not drawing
drawing it back with the arrow in the string unless you are ready to shoot. Right? So the
the trouble they're facing is urgent. It's not just urgent. It's also unpredictable. Right? So they're
in the they're shooting at the upright in heart, but they are in the dark as they do that. In
other words, they can't see where this attack is going to come from. So it's unpredictable.
But another thing it's existential, you might say. So it threatens to undermine and destroy
the very, the very foundation of their society as the people of God. So where do we see that?
Let's let's read verse three. They say if the foundations are destroyed, what can the righteous do?
So they're panicking. The question is, does David join them in their panic? Will he join in this
kind of fervor in this desire to just run away? And the answer is no, because of what he
says at the very start of the psalm in the Lord, I take refuge. So how can you say those things to me?
Refuge is in the Lord. So while others are heading for the hills, he stays right where he is. Why?
Because his confidence is in the Lord. You know, a couple of weeks ago in Psalm 10, we saw that
the Lord is the most high God. That he is our high tower. And so they're fleeing for the
hills to this place of protection. But remember, if God is most high, if he is our high tower,
there is no greater place of security than in him. So why flee to the mountains when you know the Lord
as your high tower? So when others flee, he stands firm. So here's, I guess, the question we then
wrestle with. So how will we respond in the face of opposition as believers today?
While we're not in a part of the world where we're facing active persecution, we are still in a culture
and a society where in many ways, which in many ways is diametrically opposed to the way of Christ.
So you can be shamed and excluded for taking a stand on what Scripture clearly teaches. If
you're following the way of Jesus, you could be shamed for that for sure. We live in a broken
society where we're facing lots of dangers of just like living in a broken world. And as we look at
the kind of cultural movements that are away from Christ or legislation that's not in line with the
truths of God's Word or just the general threat of living in a place where violence is the norm.
How should we react? How do we respond when we see or think about those things?
Well, there's definitely some that surrender, you know, that just adapt to whatever the cultural
norms are around them and, you know, they may abandon their faith altogether or just like adapt
it to just fit in with whatever the popular way of thinking is at the time, whatever the general
consensus of the wider culture is. There's that kind of surrender. But there's also,
which is what we're reading about in the Psalm, a tendency to retreat as well. A kind of moral
panic can set in over whatever the presenting issue of the day is. And, you know, it'll change from
year to year, but that same kind of panic can be there. Sometimes the threats are real, sometimes
they are imagined, sometimes they are overstated. And, you know, the algorithms on our social
media accounts can like feed into that kind of that fear or panic. And it can confirm to us
that we are right to worry because look at how bad it is now compared to how it was before.
And some reason, like every four years when elections season rolls around, it seems to be
even worse. There's more reasons to be afraid than you realized. Interestingly, I've actually
heard verse three used to kind of almost justify that kind of fear driven panic about the
foundations of America. Like if the foundations are destroyed, what will the righteous do?
Couple of quick things about that. One, believe it or not, this was definitely not written about
the foundation of America, that verse. And two, it's almost certainly put here before us as a
fear driven overstatement. Like the people giving bad advice are saying like, if the foundations
are destroyed, what will the righteous do? And David is going to go on to say essentially,
there's a foundation that cannot be destroyed. And if your foundation is something that can
be destroyed, then you're building your life in the wrong place altogether. So when others are
thrown into a panic about threats real or imagined, what are we to do? We're to practice the sacred
act of staying put, of continuing to take refuge in the Lord and knowing that He will provide
all that we need to stay faithful, to continue in the faith, to persevere to the end until we
see Him. In 1 Corinthians, Paul is writing to a church that's facing all kinds of threats in terms of
like morality. They're taking on the immorality of the world in the church. They're starting to
consider false doctrines as well, attacks on the truth of God's Word. And they're not responding well.
And so Paul addresses those issues head on, but I love where he eventually ends up in the book.
He points them to the risen Christ and shows that He is risen from the dead.
In His kingdom will never end. It will not be shaken. And then he says, in light of this,
in light of who your Savior is, 1 Corinthians 15-58, be steadfast, immovable, inmovable,
always abounding in the work of the Lord. So when others are surrendering or retreating,
we stand firm in the Lord. So what I want us to do is to just see three kind of final things from
the Psalm that show us like why and how we practice this sacred act of staying put,
like how we can stand firm in the Lord. So the first way is or the first reason why,
rather, is a line I'm going to borrow from Eugene Peterson. It's we stand firm in the Lord
because, number one, God hasn't changed a dress. God hasn't changed a dress. So let's see verse 4.
It says, the Lord is in His holy temple. The Lord's throne is in heaven. So here's what he's saying.
Why would I run somewhere else when the Lord hasn't gone anywhere? So people are saying,
David flee, but he hangs on because the Lord is in His holy temple. Now remember, like this
is written before the physical temple was built. This is speaking of God's heavenly dwelling.
It is His holy presence. God has not gone anywhere. The foundation of His holy
dwelling will never be destroyed. He hasn't gone anywhere.
The Lord's throne is in heaven, he says. So if the temple speaks of God's presence,
His throne is speaking of His governing power. So in other words, no matter what happens here,
the Lord is still on the throne. He still reigns. So you don't have to panic because He's still in
control. One of the things that King George is most known for is his response in World War II,
particularly his response to not leave London. So London was being bombed during World War II
and King George made it public that he wasn't going anywhere. He was there bucking in palace.
He was going and visiting sites that had been bombed. And that was a real kind of morale boost
for the country because the King wasn't going anywhere. So people were able to better stand firm.
And I loved what his wife, the Queen, said. People were suggesting that she and her
daughters evacuate to North America or perhaps to Canada. And to this she made a famous reply.
She said, the children won't go without me. I won't leave the King and the King will never leave.
Her position was clear. The King will never leave, so I'm not going anywhere either.
So here's what David's saying in the psalm. No matter what we are facing,
the King isn't going anywhere. The Lord is there. He is still in control. We might feel like our life
is crumbling to pieces all around us, but even then he will still be there. The King will never
leave you nor forsake you, as it says in Hebrews 13. The thing is we need a bedrock
of stability to build our lives on because the sands of the world are always shifting.
Nick and I went to a conference a couple weeks ago and one of the main speakers was a guy from
Oxford, England called Alistair McGrath. And he gave some wonderful lectures, but one of the things
that he brought out was how it's important to distinguish between what is a cultural moment
and what is a timeless truth. Because in terms of how people think and believe or even how
people dress, I mean you look back at a photo album from the 1970s and you can't help but laugh,
seeing your family and their dads in the plaid suits or the bell bottoms or that sort of thing.
And then after a while you start looking at it and thinking, okay in like 20, 30 years time,
like what are people going to start thinking about how I was dressed at the time, 2025?
It's like we don't realize the cultural moment that we are in. The thing is trends come and go,
not just in fashion, but also in the way people think and the values that they hold
and how they live in the world around them. We might think like no, I'm not giving sway to that,
but actually we are more, we're adapting more to our culture perhaps than we realize sometimes.
A couple of examples of this, one is the new atheism and Alistair McGrath spoke about that
that I remember back in 2008, 2009, going through almost like a crisis of faith. I had just moved
overseas and it was the kind of rise of this new atheism which is basically, if you're not
familiar with it, it's a kind of a militant form of atheism that it's not just, oh I happen to
not believe in God, but I don't believe in God and you shouldn't either and it's evil in society
too, believe so, here's all the damage. It's a really kind of in-your-face form of atheism.
You have people like Richard Dawkins or Christopher Hitchens at the time who were
kind of gaining momentum and I remember feeling threatened by that and it really felt like all
the world was going to move towards that, towards the absence of God and like what does that mean
for my faith or the faith of those around me? But here I won't get into all the kind of
arguments about atheism and atheism and that sort of thing, but just to point out that
a while the rise of their popularity at the time was very real, today the cultural conversation
has very much moved on. Like that was a moment that came and it was also a moment that went
and it's not to say that there's not other things that we're facing today, but just to
say like what seemed like it was going to change everything, well just wait about 10, 15 years,
there's going to be something else. So today you hear about a bit more like say express
individualism as being more of a thing. In other words like the point of life is to look
inwardly to discover who you truly are and to express that in the world around you and have
others to affirm your kind of yet that individual expression of who you are. We could name other
things, but we face that pressure now, but it may change in the future, it will change in the
future. We live in a world where perspectives are always changing, but all that's to say this,
one of the most wonderful things and compelling things about biblical Christianity is that it has
deep roots and that it has stood the test of time and it is something that can and will be passed
on to future generations. As all these trends come and go and how people think and what the
presenting issues are, there is a constant and that is Christ who is the same yesterday, today,
and forever. Paul said this to Timothy in 2 Timothy chapter 2 and verse 19, he says God's firm
foundation stands. He says it bears this seal, the Lord knows those who are His. So yeah sure
it can be helpful to be aware of cultural trends and ways of thinking, but we don't have to
panic about them because the Lord remains. He will not change address and so we find our home in Him.
The second thing we see here, God uses troubles to test. So verse 4,
but the second part of it, after he says the Lord's throne is in heaven, he says,
his eyes see, his eyelids test the children of man. So when you hear the word test, don't think like
taking a test in school, it's not like how we respond in times of trouble is like,
you're going to get graded and it's like, oh, she's doing really well so she gets an A plus,
so she gets into heaven, whereas there he is worrying again and he's got a D minus,
he's barely hanging on, he may get an F next time. It's not like that, the Lord testing in that way.
I mean if you want to go with that picture, it might be more like a group project or something,
where you were sick and you were with the best kid in class, they ace it, they get a perfect
score and you get the perfect score as well, not because you contributed anything, but because
you were with them. And so Christ lived a perfect life, even in his hardest of trials
and his righteousness is credited to the account of everyone who is united to him by faith,
we contribute nothing. Yet we receive everything in him. But here, when it's speaking about testing,
when it says the Lord tests, it basically means this, it means that he sees us for who we truly
are and shows us that we belong to him by refining us through trials. So he sees us, first of all,
speaks about the Lord's eyes, his knowledge. So says his eyes see. Earlier David was told,
like, these arrows are flying at you in the dark. He doesn't see where the danger is coming from,
but now he's saying, but hang on a second, the Lord sees. Like he knows what's going on,
he's not in the dark. He sees everything. And by the way, this gives us assurance, you know,
in our times of trial, we do not understand everything that is, is going on, but the Lord
sees all of it. And that's not just an abstract thing or a theoretical thing. He sees you and
he sees your situation and he understands what we're facing far better than we do and what we
need to press on. He goes on to say his eyelids test the children of man. So it's
interesting it goes from eyes to eyelids. I'm not totally sure as to why it does that, but
one thing that's been suggested is that bringing up eyelids as opposed to eyes is that when your
eyelids get more involved, what are you doing? You're, you're squinting and you might squint
when you give like more focused attention to something. All right. So if the Lord is
giving more focused attention to something, what is he doing? He's certainly he's testing. So
he's, he's evaluating. He's scrutinizing. He's testing. So to say that is to say that he, he
gives focused attention and sees us for who we truly are. And this is true of everyone.
And so what the Psalm then does is it then takes what we have in Psalm one says when
he tests the children of man and the children of man are broken up into these two groups,
the righteous and the wicked. And the Lord knows who are the righteous, those who belong to him.
And he knows who the wicked are, those who are heading for destruction.
So as the Lord looks on, he knows he sees those who are his. But also he shows
that we belong to him by refining us through the trials that we face. So we see not only
the Lord's eyes, but his heart. We see his affections for his, his people there. So let's,
let's read verse five. It says, the Lord tests the righteous, but his soul hates the wicked
and the one who loves violence. So here we see a kind of contrast between how God views and deals
with the righteous and deals with the wicked. Now remember, the righteous are not those who
are perfect, like who've aced the test. The righteous are those who have put their trust in the Lord,
the those who've been clothed in the righteousness of Christ. Okay. And he deals with them differently
to the wicked. In verse five and six, we see how God is against the wicked and their evil
deeds. And hard times are heading their way because of it when he brings about their demise.
But he puts that in contrast to how he deals with the righteous when he tests the righteous,
because the hard times that the righteous face are not coming from a God who is against them,
or who a God who, or from a God who is trying to trip them up, but rather a God who is for them
and able to use trial to bring about good in their life. The word used for test here is
actually a craftsman's word. It was used in the context of refining gold and silver,
like a silversmith would take a piece of gold and they would refine it in a fire and they
would shape it. So it was for shaping and purifying in the hands of the craftsman.
That kind of action is testing it in the fire. So both the righteous and the wicked
the wicked go through hard times, but the righteous are being brought through those hard
times are being brought through the fire. Not that they might be destroyed, but that they might
be proven and refined. It's like what Job said in Job 23 in verse 10. He said,
but he the Lord knows the way that I take and when he has tried me I shall come forth as gold.
So here's what this means. If you've placed your life in the Lord's hands,
you don't need to run away when you go through a trying time. As hard as it is, you can stay put
living in the hope that you are in the hands of the God who cares for you and will use
even this to refine you like gold. In our fiery trials, he is shaping us in the likeness of his Son.
And one of the areas of Christ's likeness that he is shaping us in as we go through trials is the
steadfastness of Christ, his perseverance. This past week I was reading in the Gospel of Luke,
and there comes a big transition point in the Gospel of Luke which says that Jesus
sets his face towards Jerusalem. He knows that the cross is coming. He's determined that he is going
to go there in spite of the hardship that he is going to face. So with the help of his spirit,
we can follow his example even when we face hardships. The Lord uses that. Let me give you
a verse in the New Testament, a couple of verses that get very specific about this. James chapter
1 verses 2 to 4 says, Count it all joy, my brothers and sisters, when you meet trials of various kinds,
for you know that the testing of your faith produces steadfastness. And let steadfastness
have its full effect that you may be perfect and complete, lacking in nothing. So yes,
patient trust in times of trial is a grace in and of itself, but do you see what James is saying there?
He's saying as you steadfastly look to the Lord in times of trial, the Lord uses that to grow you
in all kinds of ways. So continuing on with the Lord in that context is where he grows us.
All right, so one final thing. All right, so we stand firm in the Lord, knowing that he's not
gone anywhere, his address hasn't changed, and he uses our troubles to test us, to refine us,
to show that we belong to him. And then finally, God promises something better. He promises something
better. That's how we can stand firm. Once again, just like Psalm 1 verses 6 and 7 put
not only the righteous and the wicked before us, but the future that they can anticipate.
Here we see that the Lord is righteous and he promises a future where everything will be made right.
Now the future for the wicked is bleak. Verse 6 is there. He says,
let him rain coals on the wicked, fire and sulfur and a scorching wind, shall be the portion of their
cup. The language being used here is actually hearkening back to the destruction of Sodom
and Gomorrah in Genesis 19. And that said he is destroyed for its pride and wickedness.
There is coming a day when a day of judgment when all who oppose God and his righteousness will be
brought to a terrible end. And this is a fearful thing. But this reminds us of the truth that
a day will come when sin and all of the devastation that came about as a result will be brought to an
end. And so the future that we can look forward to is a future of righteousness where sin is no
longer there and all the destruction that it is it has caused. So 2 Peter chapter 3 verse 13
tells us that the home that we have to look forward to is the new creation where righteousness
dwells. So we see the future of the righteous here as well. So what is the better thing that is
promised to the righteous? What is our portion? Verse 7, the Lord is righteous. He loves righteous
deeds. We'll end with this. The upright shall behold his face. So we stand firm in times of
trial in the hope that one day we will behold the face of the Lord. Alright so David's advisors,
remember they're saying behold. They use that word there in verse 2, behold the wicked.
And he ends the Psalm saying no, no, no, no. I'm going to behold his face. That's my hope. Do you
see the difference? And some people might think well what's the big deal about the holding
somebody's face, the Lord's face? Like what's going on here? Well the fact is you want to behold the
face of someone that you love. Someone who is looking upon you in love as well. So this is the
language of a loving, satisfying relationship. This relationship will go on forever. We're satisfied
as we look upon the face of the one who loves us and gave himself for us. So the fact is in
Christ. I mean it's amazing to think David here is saying we will be able to hold the face of the
Lord. I'm just mind boggling. But now that we have the New Testament we see that it's in Christ
that we behold his face. We do this by faith now but one day our faith will be made sight.
And in Christ we will see that the Lord is so good that every trial was worth it.
It will be worth it all. So 1 Peter chapter 4 verse 12. Peter says, beloved do not be surprised
at the fiery trial when it comes upon you to test you. As though something strange were happening
to you but rejoice insofar as you shared in Christ's sufferings. Hear this, that you may also
rejoice and be glad when his glory is revealed. So beholding his face, seeing his glory brings great
joy that will make all the suffering worth it. I wouldn't say I was suffering in 2008 but it
wasn't a difficult, or it was a difficult year in some ways. It was my last year of
the Bible college I was studying at. And I was doing my studies. It was my final year. So you
got to give a lot of attention to that. I was also working at a warehouse at the time. I also knew
I was about to move countries. And so there was the whole like getting your visa sorted out and not
knowing whether or not your application would be accepted or not. And then there was all the
money, the cost of actually applying for all that and getting your flight tickets. So there's
a whole lot involved in saying goodbye to a whole lot as well in the U.S. too. Stepping
into a completely unfamiliar place, like not knowing what life ahead of me was going to look like.
You know, I had the promise of a part-time job in ministry, so not a promise of a lucrative future.
But there was something in front of me that made me think, oh, this is going to be worth it.
And of course the Lord would meet me there. But what I'm thinking of particularly was what
was going to happen on August 30th, 2008. And I remember it like yesterday, standing at the front
of a church building. You know, I'm standing right here at the front. And I wasn't preaching at the
time. I was a giddy groom waiting for my brides to come through the door over there. And so
Julia then came around the corner. And as soon as she got to the corner, people were standing,
as soon as she hit the corner, like her face was veiled. But I could see through and I could see it.
And the anticipation grew and the joy grew as she made her way down to the front. And then the veil
was lifted. The most beautiful thing I've ever seen in her face. And while I was standing there,
I wasn't thinking, yeah, this has been a really hard year. I don't know, I've made the right
decision. You know, I wasn't thinking about all of the hardship. I was enraptured in the joy of that
moment. But you know, there's something much greater to come. You know, we, we, you know,
what it means to know the Lord is to behold Christ by faith now. So yes, we see through a veil.
But we can behold him by faith now. But there's coming to a day when the veil will be
lifted and we will behold his beauty, his glory, and he will fully satisfy. So we can stand firm in
trying times, knowing something is better, better is promised. We can stand in trying times, knowing
that it will be, as the old hymn says, just quote it, it will be worth it all when we see
Jesus. Life's trials will seem so small when we see Christ. One glimpse of his dear face,
all sorrow will erase. And then it says, so bravely run the race till we see Christ. So whatever
you're facing, keep looking to Jesus. Press on by God's grace toward him, towards the one who,
for the joy that was set before him, endured the cross, despising the shame, is now sat down at the
right hand of the Father. We're coming now to the Lord's table. And as we come to this table,
we are looking back on what Christ has done for us. And we're also looking forward to the day when
we see him face to face. The bread reminds us of his great trial at the cross when his body was
broken for us. The wine reminds us of when his blood was shed for us.
So we're invited to come to this table remembering what he has done for us,
looking to him by faith. When we take of this bread and we're drinking of this cup,
we're saying, Lord, I'm trusting in you and we're communing with him together as the Lord's people
at his table. We're remembering and putting our faith in his death for us and looking forward to
the day when he returns. And so we're going to partake in this together. But what I want us
to do right now is to just take a time of prayer before the Lord and a time of
committing whatever we're struggling with to him, putting, repenting of sin, putting our trust in
Christ and asking that he would prepare our hearts to remember him in this way. So let's pray and
then I'll pray and give thanks. So let's pray just where you're sat.